we begin with china where manufacturing
continues to recover
a key measure the purchasing manager's
index reached the highest level in
october since
january 2011. it's just the latest sign
of a recovering economy
in the asian powerhouse another well the
return of business in
wuhan the central chinese city where the
outbreak began
take a look
social distancing rules are out clubbing
there are no more problems in wuhan
everything's under control
a message beijing is eager to spread
especially as europe locks down and
cases rise again in the u.s
new figures increasingly support that
message the chinese economy is growing
again
exports are rising and domestic
consumption is trying to pick up the
slack in overseas demand
businesses say they're seeing the
revival first hand baldehong
owns one of the city's most popular
restaurants
we started to ease the lockdown on april
8th but the customers weren't there
it was only in may when everyone was
tested that people and families started
going out
because everyone was reassured
but china's approach is hardly
duplicable beijing's one-party rule
and its massive mobilization make it an
anomaly amongst large economies
even if its rebound is enviable
well for more i'm joined by our
financial correspondent conrad business
in frankfurt
conrad the data from china certainly is
going down well after a dismal week
isn't it
absolutely monika after the german index
tax
lost nearly 10 in the course of the
month of october
this data from china is really taken by
investors as
a an injection of optimism i would say
it's really causing
a rebound on the market here but at the
same time
you know as all over europe new
lockdowns at
least partial lockdowns are being
introduced
there's also a lot of discussion on the
trading floor how good
is it and how long can germany's
economy continue to rely so much on
china
so a little bit of optimism there from
china but the focus this week
certainly isn't on china
absolutely the number one topic this
week also on the european trading floors
is the election in the united states
generally speaking investors at the
moment really don't want to have too
many
risky trades open they prefer to stay on
the sidelines sit on the
fence and as donald trump would say
see what happens and not only till
wednesday
you know this election in the u.s is
going to be
one of the most contested ones ever it's
going to take a while until markets can
concentrate on
economic aspects of what's going on in
america again
all right conrad guzman frankfurt thank
you so much